ma'am you got your license for me I've
asked you like three times okay can I
have it please oh God that's so
[Applause]
C nobody's hurt you're not hurt ma'am
no
okay which way were you going no we're
right here it right in front us
we over
here where in the
intersection right in the Poli just
second you see theks that dark go like
right
there right there to right right where
[Applause]
that did you find your license insurance
and registration I have everything right
here get it no I know but they didn't
have anything I need your license
insurance and
registration let me get your info real
quick were you in that car yes sir okay
have your license insurance registration
ready which direction were you headed I
was going uh East okay East and I was
going and they you ask for anything
everybody have which lane were you in I
was in the Middle Lane heading east into
and I had a green light and and where
did the impact take place the impact
took place watch these cars here coming
for you can see the marks right here in
this right here
this
and know where she come
from I think she she coming from there
she I think she was coming straight
through okay did they tell you I had a
green light who the two witnesses they
didn't say anything about colors of
lights but I'm not concerned with colors
of lights right now okay I just want to
know
I'm you good you don't need
resue
no what can you tell me are you going to
be able to cross over to get out your
car this way or no no no I stay for the
light the light is in you were waiting
for the light to change okay guys I I
stay
here okay license insurance and
registration just have it ready for me
ma'am you got your license for me I do
nervous he's nervous he's
nervous
I'm on me too keep an eye on her I'm
going to go I'm going to go I need your
assistance right hold it for me one
second what this okay do me a favor yes
can you go to info and see if by chance
there's the Tango unit yes good and and
you know what and do me another favor
she me too she said and she's
[Applause]
drug front seat passenger yeah anybody
else in the car or no we had three kids
in the car okay
my mom picked them up okay they were all
in the back yeah
SE I'm going to use this if you guys
want to move over here real
quick I need the insurance for the for
the truck whatever Insurance the truck
has thank
you here you can have the registration
so I don't lose it let me go double look
at the damage real quick we're where
where would you tell be able to tell me
was like initial impact on the car and
it probably wrapped around I'm guessing
I was going straight you were going this
way yeah I was going straight in front
of me I turned to try to avoid her so
the first impact s the first impact was
the left side driver's side so we hit
complete on but it was driver's side
left side cuz I tried to avoid her by
turning the wheel to the right can you
do me a huge favor I'm on I think his
car is good where it is can you put
yourself over here so you can help
watching oh my in your car so you can
help watching her because she's going to
I'm getting a feeling she's going to try
to Boogie on us here in a minute on foot
she's so dumb she's telling somebody on
the phone her I don't care her dl's
screwed up and they're asking her why
didn't she
flee were you able to get me your
insurance or your registration or
anything I have all that I've asked you
like three times okay can I have it
please
zinski watch in there for me
[Applause]
please hey she's taking a right
now I'm on I'm on I'm
recording
no
ma'am I need to speak with you across
the street if you don't mind okay right
over here yes ma'am I will all right all
right so first what I want to do is I
want to take a look driv in particular
way so for that come on over
here stand right here right here yes
ma'am yes you know but like right place
me you yes all right go and place your
feet together so no space in between
just keep your arms reled all the way
together okay like this I'm sorry yes
yes you side or the front feet together
hands to your side okay
okay next what I want you to do is I
want you to do you see the top of this
pen I do okay I'm going to move this pen
to your left and to your right and I
want you to follow it only with your
eyes keeping your head still do you
understand just my eyes follow it yes
just switch your eyes okay all right
let's
begin no no do I follow it or no I want
you to follow the pen only with your
eyes Fe together again all right let's
try it again all right you can say
normal
come on over here please ma'am
technically there's three lines here so
we're going to use the center
Line2 well okay so this one here one
here and then this Center Road okay so
what I want you to do is just come on
over here where now turn your body
around so you turn your body facing that
way okay so we're going to use the
center line This is Center here and
here right we're going to use this this
Center Line no wait okay so here yes O
Okay when I refer to the line that's the
line I want you to stand on okay so for
now what I like for you to do is go
ahead and place your left foot on the
line left on this line on the center
line I see it but I'm kind of off place
your right foot directly in front of
your left foot so you're standing heel
touch and toe you're going to keep your
arms into your side no I see it don't
get me wrong so when I tell you to begin
and not before you're going to take nine
steps forward nine nine steps forward
heel touching toe counting out loud with
your hands with your hands to your side
just like this one two three all the way
to nine okay after your n step you're
going to leave your front foot on the
surface and you're going to turn around
it like this by taking several Little
Steps around your front foot without
lifting your front foot off the surface
get back in position please okay okay
and then you're going to come back doing
the same thing nine steps heel touch and
toe counting out loud again watching
your feet with your hands to your side
do you understand
okay you may begin Now by taking your
first step and don't stop until you're
done okay okay I got it you may begin
now one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 what you want me to do turn around I'm
scared I don't know well just follow
through with the instructions that you
recall one two three four
five I'm sorry I don't know 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8
9 it's my
[Applause]
boyfriend how you doing
sir can I help
you okay well right now they're
conducting a DUI investigation so we'll
let you know what happens so okay she's
got involved in an accident they're
doing a DUI investigation and we'll go
from there okay all right so this next
exercise is called the one leg stand
exercise again what I'm going to do is
I'm going to explain to you I'm going to
demonstrate it I'll ask if you
understand and then I'll let you do it
okay right all right when I tell you to
begin what you're going to do is you're
going to lift either your left or your
right foot directly out in front of you
and I'm and I'm about to show you okay
um that foot needs to be directly out in
front of you you need to look at your
foot and you need to count out l for 30
seconds this is the way you're going to
do it just like this okay 1001 1002 1003
10045 1006 1007 1008 1009 110 just like
that okay okay now you're going to be
doing this for 30 seconds okay so if you
happen to place your foot down during
those 30 seconds you need to pick it
back up and continue counting from the
last number that you left off at so what
I'm saying is this if you're counting
one 1,1
10002 13 1004 see what I'm saying 1005
yes okay I it all right one sec okay how
many reps do I have to do up this it's
only going to be one rep it lasts for 30
seconds approximately I will tell you
when to stop once you begin okay and um
come on over here for this you may begin
now five 6 7
8 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8
9 all right the last exercise is call
the finger to nose exercise
okay what you're going to do is this for
that exercise your feet are going to be
together together my hands are your
hands are going to be like mine to the
side with your inck fingers pointing
down your palms facing forward
during the exercise your eyes will be
closed and your head will be tilted back
mine will not be closed right now cuz
I'm showing you how to do this okay all
right you can hear me ask for your right
arm and when I ask for your right arm
you're going to bring your right arm up
you're going to bring a tip of your Nick
finger to touch tip of your nose arm
goes automatically back down to your
side okay make sure that you use the tip
of yourick finger to the tip of your
nose right not the pad of your finger
need a be a tip like your nail is this
okay okay okay clear all right got it
come on over here can I touch this or no
why do you need to touch it oh uh well I
don't have to go that far up oh my God I
I need a little support I'm sorry okay
so I need you to turn your body to face
my
car all right so only R the fingers
pointing down okay Palms facing
forward eyes closed head tilted back and
we're going to begin
okay
left
right
a okay bring your arms down all right
just relax your arms here behind your
back
please so what I'm doing here ma'am is I
am plac you in arrest the charges
driving under the influence of an
alcoholic beverage a chemical substance
or control substance I'm sorry why is my
opinion that you're under the influence
did I not pass the test no did not pass
or fail first off and based upon how you
perform it's my opinion that you're
under the influence of an alcoholic
beverage really crazy fac these are
impaired I felt like I passed everything
okay so under Florida law you are
required to submit to a breath test to
determine the alcoholic cont of your
breath will you do that yes yeah okay
great
1,00% excellent okay 1,00% thank you
okay oh God come on this is so C oh God
babe yourself in ma'am come on hey are
you okay if he takes your stop of the
vehicle like first stop huh are you okay
if she takes your first please I want
him to take everything come on sit
back